Speaker 1: I have not talked about White House
press secretary Jen Psaki press briefings
for a while.
I've just been so busy with different elements
of the show.
I haven't been watching them.
I haven't been covering, but yesterday covering
them.
But yesterday I did get an opportunity to
see kind of what was going on and something
the more things change, the more things stay
the same.
Both Jen Psaki and Fox News reporter Peter
Doocy have had COVID.
They're both back.
And Peter Doocy is once again attempting these
takedowns of Jen Psaki and of Biden policy
on COVID.
Now, there is no shortage of criticism of
the United States, both under Trump and under
Biden when it comes to COVID policy missteps
made under both without playing false equivalency.
What Trump did is unconscionable in a completely
different way than the way that that Joe Biden
has not been as good as he could have been
when it comes to COVID policy.
But Peter Doocy tries to, in order to score
points against Jen Psaki, starts pushing anti-vax
talking points like vaccinated people are
getting it too, which of course, is a very
dangerous talking point in the abstract to
promote given the level of anti-vaccine sentiment
in the United States, given the incredibly
significant protection that vaccines provide
against hospitalization and death.
So let's just jump right in.
And I think this is an example of Jen Psaki
doing a pretty good job of refuting these
toxic talking points.
Speaker 4: I understand the science says that
vaccines prevent death, but controversial
vaccine still got COVID it triple backs.
Still, God forbid.
Why is the president still referring to this
as a pandemic?
I'm vaccinated,
Speaker 1: and of course, the answer.
Well, we'll see what Jen Psaki says.
The answer is it's disproportionately the
unvaccinated who have to go to the hospital,
who end up being intubated and who end up
dying, even though now most of the country,
but by most, I don't mean 80 90 percent, but
60 something percent.
Most of the country is vaccinated.
It is still overwhelmingly the unvaccinated
that are getting really sick.
That's what it means.
OK, now let's listen to Jen Psaki.
Speaker 5: Well, I think, Peter, there's a
significant difference between and you just
you just experienced this and not to expose
your public health experience, but I can speak
to my own mind as well.
I had been triple vaxxed.
I had minor symptoms.
There is a huge difference between that and
being unvaccinated.
You are 17 times more likely to go to the
hospital if you're not vaccinated, 20 times
more likely to die.
And those are significant serious statistics
if you suggest the impact for people who are
unvaccinated is far more dire than those who
are vaccinated.
Speaker 4: Will the president update language
in some time to be more reflective of the
fact that people who are triple vaccinated
are catching and spreading COVID?
Speaker 5: I think people per president has
set, as have we a number of times, that there
will be breakthrough cases.
There will be people who get COVID here at
different media organizations, at companies
around the world, around the country who have
been vaccinated.
But there is a significant difference between
being hospitalized or dying and being vaccinated
with more mild symptoms.
Speaker 1: So what you have to understand
is that Peter Doocy is there to try to goad
Jen Psaki into soundbites for the purposes
of later airing them on Fox News and showing
how great she did.
The questions are dumb, and they're bad questions
by design to ET because they're so stupid
that the idea is fire up Jen Psaki.
So she says something emotional or looks bad
in some way.
He is not actually there to be a reporter
and to bring information to people.
His argument essentially is seatbelt laws
haven't completely eliminated traffic deaths.
And also, sometimes even when you're wearing
a seatbelt, you can still get hurt in a car
accident.
That's basically the argument.
And if you said that to most people, they
would say that's a really stupid argument
against seatbelts, isn't it?
This is the most important of the three things
that that he kind of tries to pull.
We'll look at a couple of others in a moment.
The unvaccinated in the U.S. are more likely
to test positive, so you still do get protection
against Macron from being triple vaccinated.
But it is so contagious, and it's different
enough from what the vaccines target that
a lot of vaccinated people still ultimately
test positive, but they are significantly
less likely to end up in the hospital and
significantly less likely to die.
It's sort of like a false equivalency where
he goes, Listen, unvaccinated people get this
and vaccinated people get this.
So it's the same.
Well, no, you have to actually look at the
numbers and see what it is that we're talking
about here and.
The issue is they are coming to their conclusion
first, which is we don't like the vaccine,
we want to talk about being against it, not
Doocy personally write his shtick as I got
it, but people are asking this question because
he's doing it for the audience.
They start with, we don't want the vaccine
and then they work backwards from there.
Then they also talked about COVID testing.
I'll just show you a little bit of that.
Speaker 4: I was home all last week, isolating.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I was isolating with COVID after a positive
test.
Like a lot of people watching and a lot of
time in front of the TV, I heard the president
say, Did you watch
Speaker 5: Fox full time or other things?
Speaker 4: I had exhausted the full catalog
of Guy.
Very content.
Speaker 5: Oh, OK.
Speaker 4: Now obviously a lot of folks, but
I heard the president say Google COVID test
near me.
So somebody isolating with COVID, I did that
and the appointments everywhere were completely
jammed.
So why is it that you guys were so unprepared
for the need for testing after the holidays?
Speaker 5: Well, Peter, I'm happy to see you
back and well, I would second say that there
has been a massive surge in cases, as you
know, and we're a part of in D.C. and New
York, and there has been an unprecedented
in other parts of the country as well.
There's been an unprecedented demand for tests.
So what we have done over the course of the
last few weeks even before.
Speaker 1: So, you know, it's another gotcha.
And it is absolutely true that testing is
a disaster in the United States.
It's been a disaster for a long time.
And it's the the problem here is the continued
attempt to give people who watch fox fodder
for justifying not only not getting vaccinated,
not even looking for a test when they have
symptoms.
And then here's the last one.
This one is on Sonia Sotomayor, who
Speaker 4: has been very aggressive countering
COVID misinformation.
So what do you guys think about COVID misinformation
coming from the Supreme Court?
Speaker 1: It's kind of weird that he even
talks like this.
You know, it's like it.
What do you guys think about?
It's sort of like the way you would talk.
It's like the way a third grader would talk
to the teacher when they have a joke, you
know?
Speaker 4: And Sonia Sotomayor's false claim
that over 100000 children are in serious condition,
many on ventilators.
Speaker 5: Well, I'm not going to speak to
Supreme Court arguments or statements made
in those arguments, but I will tell you that
what is at stake here is our effort to protect
health workers and, most importantly, protect
patients.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So, you know, again, it's not that
it's invalid to touch on these issues, but
it's all meaningless.
Gotcha.
You're not really informing anyone by asking
the White House press secretary about a misstatement
made by a Supreme Court justice.
It's it's just optics and trying to goad responses.
And Jen Psaki continuing to do a pretty good
job, a pretty good job of dealing with it.